foreign
Contracting and expanding
this air is ultimately nothing
without location
sensing
nervous systems have no identity besides
conditioned delusion
eyeballs and perception are empty just
like space
the space inside all buildings is the
same
the labels we slap on them are different
focusing on differences in furniture
is like being lost in skin color
nationality or politics
these clouds of Sensations
are nebulae of Stardust
everything is air sensing
without separate entities nor labels
ideas or time
the air undergoes contract
to contract into pain
solidity separation
there are options in all contracts to
expand back into vastness
these options can take Cycles to be
exercised
avoiding the return to the nothing one
ultimately is at the center of the wheel
air frequently clings to its pain
righteousness and ideas
shielding deflecting insisting
all to avoid the infinite void
it does not come without great pain to
surrender all of one's existence
air goes through Dark Nights wild
deprogramming perception back to
emptiness
these expansions feel like psychological
deaths
purges
exorcisms
the Demonic programs are seen to be
profound servants
the devil is both One's best friend and
greatest enemy
it is the way air spars itself
not a single pupil is anything other
than this identity-less
eternity
the only thing it has is to cling to
these mirages in a shoreless sea
or exercise the option to let go
surrender
and sink into the abyss
air will forever condition itself across
endless playgrounds
Contracting and expanding in ceaseless
exploration
there is no stop button
but there is lasting well-being
the only way to access it
is to forgo self
and reunite with the void
The Well of Honey under the rock awaits
foreign